hi everyone
thank you for joining today on our
webinar on seven tips for motivating
elementary school kids during distance
learning
now the tips we'll be sharing today are
tailored to this moment but they're
really applicable more broadly as needed
i'm dan tu and i'll be kicking us off
today as well as moderating the q and a
segment
but before we get started we want to say
a special thank you to several
organizations
who have really helped us with
philanthropic support enabling us to
bring you programming like today's
session
so we want to say a special thanks to
bank of america google.org
at t fastly and novartis
so i'd like to introduce you all to
kristin diserbo who'll be walking
through the seven tips
and sharing her expert advice with you
all while we answer
your live questions kristin's our chief
learning officer here at khan academy
and an expert in learning science so if
you have any questions on today's topic
feel free to enter them into the chat we
have a team collecting them for the q a
portion
and all of this is going to be recorded
and posted since you've registered this
will automatically be emailed to you
so don't worry if you miss anything or
need to go back so with that
kristin take it away great thanks
and thanks all of you for joining today
i'm gonna
spend about oh 15 minutes or so going
through
some of the the ideas and the research
behind the tips
and then we'll open it up for questions
which i'm sure you all have lots of in
this time
so to start off with uh as dan said i'm
the chief learning officer and one of my
roles is to bring
research about learning motivation
to our understanding of how to help
students learn so
all of that that you'll see here is
based on what we understand about
motivation
from research about how to keep kids
motivated
and one of the first things to
understand is that we can really boil
down a lot of the research on motivation
to a pretty simple formula
we like to do things when first
we think we're going to be successful at
them and second
when we think there's some value to
doing that activity
which probably makes sense for you just
as much as it does for your kids who
wants to do something when you think oh
i'm probably going to fail at this
you're not likely to do it
and second you think you want to do
things that are important to you
and so as we think about how to motivate
our kids
we can think about how can i help them
feel like they're likely to be
successful
and how can i help them see some of the
value in this activity
and so this kind of simple formula
drives a lot of the tips that i'm going
to be talking about
and one of the biggest ways to help kids
feel like
they can be successful at doing
something is to help them
experience some success and one really
good way to do that
is to set goals because goals
by definition help us see that we're
making progress
and so as you think about this with
elementary age kids you want to set
really short term goals
so if you're talking kindergartners or
first graders it could be something
as simple as hey this afternoon
we're going to read this book together
or we're going to write
three sentences what are those things
that you want to work on just a very
short term
and then at the end you can say yes look
we said we were going to try to re
write three sentences we wrote four
sentences
there's an experience of success as kids
get a little older you can stretch it
out you can think about in the morning
setting goals for the day
you can think about maybe setting a a
longer maybe a week goal that then you
break down into daily goals
and the other piece when you're setting
goals is to help help kids think about
how they're going to know if they're on
track
so then one of the important pieces here
and both goal setting and monitoring and
making sure they're on track is to bring
the kids into it so instead of you
saying
our goal is this have the conversation
and say so we want to set a goal about
writing sentences how many sentences do
you think you can write today
so think about helping them set
realistic goals
and that's then going to help them be
able to also
not just see success but also they're
going to value the activity more because
they owned some of the goal setting that
went along with it
and so you get actually the the double
plus there of thinking about both
success and
value of the activity so very strong and
that's why i
encourage a lot of goal setting and
thinking about how to do that
but then when you meet them definitely
celebrate so that success
so this can be everything from high
fives to
thinking about you know small different
things that kids like to do that they
might
find successful uh we do everything
online from you know
a little online confetti to to all kinds
of things that just you know recognize
that there's an achievement there also
this can be a good time to reflect
hey what was it that helped you be
successful in meeting that goal and hey
was there a time when you were trying to
do this that it was hard and
how did you get over that how did you
get through the place where you were
stuck
and that kind of reflection helps them
then think about hey next time they get
stuck
white might be they but might be some
strategies that they could do and work
on
so definitely tip two is celebrate those
successes
then thinking about those roadblocks
think about
how you can help your children have
strategies for when
they're going to get into that that
place where they don't know what to do
and that's going to happen when you're
learning because
learning is hard and we when you're
actually engaged in learning
that you're you're learning edge right
when you're learning new things
we know that often you need a little bit
of help to get over that
but what you want to do is your kids to
have a plan for what to do
so they don't get frustrated in that
moment and before they get frustrated
you want to make the plan
so this can be everything from asking
you for help
if you're also say working from home at
the same time
as your kids are in school you might
want to think about okay how do you
signal to your kids when it's okay to
come to you and ask for help and when
they should wait
and what does that look like are there
ways they can ask their friends for help
how do they reach out for their to their
teacher in this this
kind of place what are so come up with a
list of things
um that you might be able to work
through to help your kids think about
hey if i'm stuck what are things i can
do to get
unstuck so you get before they get to
the place of frustration
they have strategies to use after that
think about emphasizing that effort
leads to success
and there's been a lot of writing
recently about
growth mindset and this idea that if you
work hard your brain
is like a muscle and the more you work
at it
the more it's ready to learn new things
and there's actually physiology in your
brain
the cells in your brain are called
neurons and when we learn new things it
makes
new connections to new neurons and that
in itself then
helps you remember the things that
you've learned and makes you a stronger
better learner
all of that is better in a better
message
and research shows kids who understand
and get some of that understanding of
how their brain works
actually do persist more than students
who just say hey
keep trying hey keep going and so
actually on
khan academy we have a growth mindset
course
where we have a couple of videos that
explain some of this
in language for kids to understand um
that can be good to just
again start thinking of those messages
that your brain is like other muscles
and it needs to keep practicing and keep
learning new things and that'll actually
make you better and a better learner
so that's the fourth tip thinking about
effort leading to success
the fifth one is to engage their
curiosity so
lots of kids are curious about different
things that
happen in the world it could be when
they're riding their bikes and they're
thinking how does
you know pushing on this pedal actually
make the wheels turn
any of those kinds of questions it's
okay if you don't know the answer
think about how you can find out answers
to those things together
and when we think about kids that are
curious about the world those are the
kids that keep
learning and keep trying to find new
things
and so you want to encourage those kinds
of questions you can also model asking
those kinds of questions so as you're
doing things around the house or
as you're doing things outside asking
questions about how the world works
and thinking about hey did you ever
wonder and how can you find the answers
to those
all of those help build up that internal
motivation to find answers and
understand the world
the the sixth tip i have is to establish
relevance so it relates to what i was
just saying about
linking things to the world but the the
other way to do this is think about what
your kids are learning
and help them link that to things that
are of interest to them
you know your kids interests better
really than even their teachers do
so if you can think about how do i help
them see how this relates to
a hobby that they're interested in how
does this relate to something they want
to be when they grow up
how does this relate to something we
talked about yesterday
all of those things help students
establish the value of what they're
learning
so when we go back to that equation that
second piece of
why should i learn this what what is
this going to help me do
how does this relate to things i'm
interested in if you can help make those
connections
kids will value the activity more and be
more likely to want to engage in it
and finally the seventh tip i hear lots
of concerns and we get lots of questions
about
should i use rewards i don't want to
like be bribing my student to work
and i would say rewards are absolutely
a part of what we do and how we reward
ourselves even those of us who
you know are successful and are good
students have tricks to keep us self
keep ourselves motivated
uh i often say and do when i'm
writing i will say if i if i write one
page here
i'll reward myself with a piece of
chocolate um you know all of that is
fine but you want to think about how to
do this wisely so
the danger of rewards is sometimes that
if a kid is
already interested in doing something
like it's already bringing them
happiness and joy
and you start rewarding it with external
things like
candy and those kinds of things they
start to lose
actually some of their internal
motivation and start thinking oh i'm
just doing this for the
reward so that's what we want to avoid
but rewards can be really good for
things that students just don't want to
do at all
but need a little bit of kickstart to
get going
and then maybe experience some of the
success experience meeting a goal in it
to get from thinking about how we can
use those extrinsic
rewards to getting to more of those
intrinsic oh
actually i am good at this i can learn
math
those extrinsic rewards are really good
at that and they don't have to be
things they can be picking what's for
dinner they can be
picking what uh tv show you watch
spending you know another
15 minutes of screen time taking a walk
with you
having some of your time individually
all of those things are good rewards
and it's also good to ask your kids
what's rewarding to them what would they
like to be rewards for things that
meeting goals and and making progress
and that way again
you're making sure you've got something
that's meaningful to them
and helping them learn how to think
about rewarding themselves and
when they need to get a little extra
kick to get something done
uh to be able to think about how to how
to use rewards wisely for themselves
so that said that gives us our
our seven tips thinking about setting
goals and monitoring progress
celebrating success help your kids
manage those roadblocks emphasize that
effort
leads to success and cured encourage
curiosity
establish relevance and use rewards
wisely
so with that i'm going to open it up
because i'm sure there are specific
questions that you have about your
situations and
how to deal with some of the things the
specifics that you're facing
so i would be glad to uh hear some of
those dan
yeah well so before we get to that um
just couple things that we'd all ask you
to do
uh first there's in the handout section
of the webinar
you can download a printable version of
these seven tips that's available in the
download section
and again if you registered and you're
actually watching this live now um once
this video this webinar is over you'll
get an email with a recording
of this webinar as well as a link to the
downloadable
so again if you want to go back and both
watch any of the
tips in particular or read about them
that will be available to you
and then secondly go ahead and start
putting in any of the questions you have
even specific examples would be great
and we'll try to get through as many of
them as possible
so with that kristin the first question
we have is from rebecca
and i think you mentioned this in terms
of tip i believe it's tip number six
how can you help kids feel like that
what they're learning
is in school and what they do is really
relevant to their lives
so the the biggest thing here is to
think about understanding what
is interesting to your kids so what it
what are things that they're interested
in is the first
the first piece and then relating things
to them so the most
common place we hear this is in math and
so there's some things that are pretty
easy
um relatable to math so one thing
is cooking cooking it turns out involves
a lot of math
specifically a lot of fractions there's
a lot there can be you know if you're
doing a double batch
how do you think about doubling a
fraction what does that look like
thinking about how that you know
actually applies
the things that they're doing apply to
their
that the daily life so cooking is always
a good example for
uh for a lot of math issues um
there are also things that you can think
about
what do they want to be when they grow
up maybe they don't know
that's okay too you can think about what
kinds of careers
are these are the skills they're
learning good for
um so hey these are the kind of things i
know
we are we don't know what you want to be
when you grow up you haven't decided
what you want to be wrong
it's a good idea to kind of experience a
bunch of different find out about a
bunch of different possibilities
so hey this thing that we're learning
now um
it turns out that this is something that
accountants use a lot or this is
something that uh
someone who's who's doing a lot of um
who's an oceanographer learns a lot
about these
topics that you're learning about in
science today
thinking about those the kinds of
careers that link to the different
different things that they're learning
is another way to bring
some of this to life and i would also
not hesitate to reach out to your kids
teachers for
help in thinking about hey can you give
us a preview of what's coming
and what do they think are good ways to
help them relate that
to to things they see in their lives but
there's lots of things in our everyday
lives i gave the bicycle
example well it turns out that's all
about simple machines and pulleys and
chains and all of that
um so all of those kinds of examples of
how the world works we can find
things that kids are learning that
relate to them but it takes some work i
will admit
that's great kristin i would say like
one thing as well as
use all of your senses as a parent like
there are things that the child might
not tell you like they want to do this
so they want to do that but you know
your child
best and if you know that they love
doing this activity
yeah and just be observant of that and
try to relate that back to
that again back to the the subject
cool so um kristen we have a question
from
jay tinder apologies if i mispronounce
the name
any tips for helping motivate elementary
kids transitioning to middle school
in a distance learning environment so
really that transition period
um meeting new friends those types of
things so any advice you have there
so there's a number of things that go on
when kids transition to middle school so
you mentioned dan meeting new friends
there's also kids that are
taking on and required to take on a
little bit more
ownership a little bit more
self-responsibility
and if in when we talk about distance
learning one of the things we know about
distance learning is that kids who are
best at it
are kids who are what we call
self-regulated learners
so those are kids that are actually
capable of setting goals
capable of monitoring their own progress
kids that are
can create you know organize schedules
for themselves
and but those those are all skills that
you can help your child
with so think about helping them set up
what is their you know schedule for the
day because the other piece that often
happens in middle school is you start
switching teachers
where in elementary school you just had
one now you have multiple teachers
so help your child think about how do
they set out a schedule of what the day
looks like so they
make sure to know what the expectations
are help them think about
and and let them be part of the process
let them you know you can maybe give
them a skeleton and let them
fill it out and next time they create
the what this next week they create what
the schedule looks like
so kind of gradually pulling back from
the things
that you're doing and letting them have
some ownership and some agency
and it turns out that um a lot of kids
are really motivated by that if they
know that you've kind of got them there
as a safety net
and that you you're there to kind of
catch them if things get too rough
so i would say give them a little bit
more agency they're going to then
find more ownership and value in the
activities because they're driving them
and choosing them
um and and help them see that and take
on a little bit more of that ownership
um dan you mentioned you know the the
pieces about making new friends and
often middle schools are bringing
together a bunch of elementary schools
and now that we're at distance it's so
difficult to
create some of those peer connections
and peers start to become more and more
important for kids at this age level so
the
the more you can help facilitate things
in this distance environment it's we're
really limited but
facilitating you know at least calls or
hangouts ways for kids to informally
connect with each other
um and be able to do some activities
together online
that maybe they wouldn't be able to do
in person these days
but to help keep some of those those
peer relationships going and to try to
build them
um in these new places but understand
the other piece you may just
you know do is to empathize with your
kids and say
i know this is tough right now and this
is going to be difficult
as we're moving forward and i know you
miss your friends and
let's you know just give them a chance
to share with you and to express some of
what they're feeling too as they're
kind of making some of these transitions
yeah i think that's a great point chris
great points i think when you transition
to middle school not only do you have
more teachers
that you have you have to control your
schedules more you know which classrooms
are you going to when so you're learning
a lot of like
agency and being responsible getting the
class on time
and and like you said you're meeting
like tons of new kids from different
schools and different experiences that
time
at the same time so i do think there's
there's a lot of challenges
for those kids absolutely and if you can
pinpoint which things your kid is good
at and highlight those and find out
where
some of the weaknesses are and help
support those
that's a good you know way for you to
help support them and
and tailor it to what their needs are
so we have a question from dora i think
we get we hear this question a lot is
you know how do you manage
roadblocks so when your child has
self-doubt or developing low
self-esteem especially in this distance
learning environment um
how do you manage those and help the
child overcome those moments
yeah so kids who are you know
not feeling like they're learners or
they're feeling like
math is not for me i'm not you know
not good at these things i don't know
how to do this
all of those are things where um kids
can really
benefit from things like the
growth mindset piece that i was talking
about this idea that
none of us is fixed in our ability to do
things
we can always get better and getting
better takes work
but it's actually pretty rewarding to
when you start to see
hey i used to be able to do this and now
i can do this
uh here's a new thing that i can do now
that i couldn't do before
so one give them the messages about
thinking about we can always improve our
brains improve our brains change
as we try new things that's really
important but also
thinking about um helping them
experience some success so
those small goals and thinking about how
how to get them to exceed a little bit
of progress that they're making and even
a little bit of progress is good
yesterday you couldn't do the you know
two digit
by minus two digit problems and today
you did three of them
that's great like legitimately that's
progress
that's very good so helping them see
again
that they can have a little bit of
success and that really does build on
itself
and help kids start to see themselves as
learners
and that's really the key that then will
kick things off
great so christian we have a lot of
questions and it goes back to the very
first tip which is setting goals so we
have a couple of questions around goals
um first from tsuki she loves the idea
of setting goals but they're already
being set by the school
so there's you know how do you match
what your the goals that your schools
are setting
another question from flavia fabio is
like how do we know we're setting goals
at the appropriate level
right um and is you know whether it's
too challenging not challenging enough
and then the third is from ev who's
asking for very specific examples for
their grade school school kid um they're
having
challenges with getting their child to
help set their own goals
got it so yeah lots of lots of good
stuff so the first thing i would say
that underlies all of those is
think about talking to your child's
teacher even in this distance world
keeping those lines of communication
open
so if a teacher starts hearing like
all of the things that you're asking us
to do every
day is too much like the kids can't
handle that much
and they start hearing that from parents
they're gonna adjust what they're doing
or they're gonna
you know start to find ways to help the
students and provide more support
one or the other but if the teacher
doesn't know
that the kids are struggling to do this
and it can be difficult to know that
when they are
in a distance learning situation um then
they don't know that the kids need extra
help or that they need
uh need to think about how much they're
they're putting on kids
because a lot of teachers may have tons
of experience
doing all of this in the regular
classroom but it's not clear how much
kids can
take on in these distance learning
situations so
that's my first um a piece of advice is
to think about
how to you know talk to your teacher
about if the goals are too much
or if they're if they're thinking about
you know if they're not um meeting them
or where they need to go
and dan i have lost there were a bunch
of questions there and i've lost
in my short-term memory a couple of the
other points could you
remind me of what those are so so the
the other one is how do we know when
when when it's like the right level of
goal for the child in addition to
future one um and i think the third one
was
um how do you get your kids to kind of
play in the goal setting
if your kids reluctant to kind of engage
with the goal-setting exercise right so
if they're not happy to share with you
what they think like how do you
pull that out of them great yeah so the
the um the level of goals piece is
another one
to it's really good to talk to your
students teacher talk to your kids
teacher
um about you know what kinds of levels
that they're at
because it is going to be individual for
kids but when it should be of something
that you're looking for you want kids to
if you're
kind of observing them do work you want
to think about there's something where
they have to put in effort and there's
something that we talk about that's
called
productive struggle and it means that
kids are
they're having to put in some cognitive
efforts like think hard about this and
reason through it and it's not just
coming easy to them
if it's coming really easy it's probably
too low a goal if they're getting really
frustrated it's probably too high a goal
so something kind of in between there is
what you're looking to hit
where there there is a little bit of
struggle going on maybe they're a little
bit confused maybe they're not sure how
to do this
maybe they need a little bit of help
that is all okay that those are all
signs
that they're right about at the right
place they don't need to be doing it
independently if they can just breathe
through it independently
probably too easy um so that's kind of
what you're looking for in terms of
where
where to set what that is but a good
guide is
is looking at the things that your
teachers your child's teacher is
assigning
and thinking about you know how that can
how you can help
break that down the other piece to that
first question was you know it seems to
be too much
that's being assigned again think about
breaking down into small pieces so you
can see
a little bit of progress even after an
hour what are we going to try to do
in this hour i know it's a whole bunch
of stuff let's just focus on the thing
we can get them now
and then we can worry about the rest of
it later so all of that is good goal
setting and then if you've got
kids that are just like are are not
engaging and are
not that good at setting goals um
we can we can think about again the
that idea of um rewards and
thinking about how engaging them and
maybe if
you're initially setting a goal and then
having them in the conversation about
what they think maybe would be a good
reward for
getting into that and getting reaching
that goal
so all of that can kind of help bring
them into the process
and what that is so maybe they're not
interested in setting the goal
the first time um but then you can think
about what's the reward for that
or you can think about rewards for
helping set goals
getting very kind of uh meta there but
that again rewards can be good for
helping kids start doing something that
they're not interested in doing
um so think about you know hey let's set
this goal and then we can go
and you know chase around in the
backyard with a dog for
30 minutes and then we can get back to
work on meeting it
those kinds of things you know are all
good ways to start to kind of encourage
that behavior
that's great and we have a question we
have a couple questions around feedback
um and that that portion of the tips so
rebecca asks what type of feedback is
most helpful for kids
and does it depend on the stage of where
they're learning so
things like the frequency of the
feedback the timing
um when to acknowledge you know um
basically effort versus like results
things like that
yep yep oh good excellent questions
uh this is actually some place where
there's a a pretty good amount of
research out there
so when you are just learning a new
thing
you want to give immediate feedback
that is both about whether it's correct
or not but also
why it's correct or not so that's called
what we call elaborated feedback because
it's not just the correctness but it's
the why
and so you want that to be specific to
the the task
that they're doing you don't want to
give that general feedback like oh
you're so smart
you want to keep it as you got that
question
right good job that quest that answer is
right because
x y z um or you didn't get that one
right that time
that answer is not correct because of x
y z let's try again
um again don't make it about
characteristics
of the child uh you want to think about
trying to give
feedback so feedback on correctness and
about
why it's correct or not is good and you
can also then
combine that with feedback about effort
so something like wow if you're seeing
that productive struggle that i was
talking about like they worked pretty
hard to get to this
answer like wow i saw you really
thinking hard about that that's great
let's take a look at whether we got it
right or wrong or whether we want to try
again
um and then you can move into the the
correctness feedback
as kids are more advanced and they're
getting into more
advanced topics and are kind of more
comfortable with things
it's actually good to have them have a
chance to reflect on
whether they think something's correct
or not and so we do things like saying
how confident are you in that answer
how sure you how sure are you that
that's right um
and get them to actually start building
some of those skills where they're kind
of
mentally checking their own work which
is a good skill to have
and think about and then give them the
feedback
it can be a little bit more delayed it
doesn't need to be quite as immediate
as kids are getting a little bit more
advanced so
um perhaps we have time for one more
question unfortunately we have a lot
more questions than we have time for so
um we'll we'll try to you know
potentially address it in a future in a
future webinar but
um melissa asks and it's a little bit
related to feedback which is when should
you step back
and i allow a break if your child is
just really reluctant or really
frustrated
um how when do you recognize that and
then
when do you actually engage or when do
you disengage
yeah excellent question so first i would
say
we want to prioritize our kids emotional
well-being in in all of this we don't
want to let kids get to the point where
they're
you know breaking down in tears about
things because that's going to
take a lot to then walk back and
get down and get settled and where that
is so
the more you can be proactive in
scheduling in
breaks and taking a step away even
before
they're showing signs of being upset um
those are that's actually good too so
don't be hesitant to take breaks
breaks are good for everybody but if you
if you
kind of gotten through there but your
child is still like really frustrated
absolutely take a break see go back to
those strategies
okay you know let's take a break do
something else
and then when it's time to go back have
a little bit of discussion about what's
really frustrating them what is where is
that roadblock
is that they don't they don't know what
to do you know next they can't
get this right they can't understand it
you know
then you can start to problem solve
about okay if you understand
what what it is that's so frustrating um
it's
it that it's just too much that they're
thinking about is it that
you know they're worried about um all
the other things going on in the world
or they
where are those things so the more you
can have a conversation take a break
get away from it then have a
conversation about
what how are they feeling what are the
things that are they're worried about
what are the things that are frustrating
them
and see if you can problem solve some of
those together but absolutely
um look for those body language signs
that kids are getting really
uh upset and frustrated and try to cut
things off if you can before it gets too
far down that road
well i i think that's great advice for
adults as much as kids i think that's a
good advice
for for us all to follow so so a huge
apologies we have so many more questions
um
like like i said perhaps we can tackle
more in a future webinar
um but with that i'd like to thank
kristin for her sharing her
expert advice with our audience and we
want to thank you our audience for
taking time out of your busy schedule
uh to be with us we know you know you're
incredibly busy during this time
and so we really appreciate you
investing your time to this session
um if you missed anything or want to go
back and review again this is
being recorded and not only are we going
to post it but for those of you who have
registered
this will automatically be emailed to
you and in addition to that as well as
the downloadable with the seven tips
that that kristen
mentioned before so don't miss you know
don't worry if you missed anything
and we also have quite a few resources
at khan academy.org if you
need more information and before we sign
off we want to ask that you do
two things for us first please uh
give us answer the poll that happens at
the end that pops up at the end of this
webinar
we want to ask you know how can we make
teacher iterations of this session even
better for you
and then secondly what kind of other
sessions would you like to see us
develop in the future
and we're here to help you so please let
us know how we can best do that
and so from all of us at khan academy
thank you and goodbye